[Musique]
ce pont est un projet ancien que j'ai
initié quand je suis arrivée au conseil
départemental
je me suis battu et finalement vous
voyez aujourd'hui on arrive au bout de
nos peines puisque le pont va être
livrée
les habitants de la plaine de bois de
nèfles et de tous les écarts vont
pouvoir descendre vers les bas dans des
meilleures conditions et je salue là
aussi la qualité du travail des
entreprises de la réunion des
travailleurs des ouvriers qui ont su
réaliser une belle heure ici sur
aravinda pleine opération singulière à
plus d'un titre parce que c'est à elle
seule
l'équivalent d'une année de consommation
de budget d'investissement pour toutes
les routes départementales
une opération très lourde financièrement
mais qui a été largement atténuée pour
les dépenses publiques départementales
par des financements européens à hauteur
de 10 millions par des financements
régionaux à hauteur de 3,5 millions et
un petit complément apporté à la créole
entre 4 4 2 500 mille euros
[Musique]
oui
donc c'est un ouvrage qu'on va qualifier
de non courant puisque c'est un ouvrage
à ossature mixte donc acier béton 730
tonnes d'acier avec quatre arcs donc
surbaissé encaissons sur lequel vient se
s'ériger un treillis tridimensionnel
tubulaire donc tout ça fait que c'est un
ouvrage complexe à réaliser
nous sommes confrontés à des bouchons
assez important 2
en direction de caen b et de savannah
donc je pense que ce rond point est ce
futur pont pourrait peut-être
effectivement beaucoup plus fluide la
circulation vers vers le bas il a été
long à sortir de terre mais c'est un bel
ouvrage au dessus de sites préservés
pleine nature c'est très très attendue
par les habitants notamment du bois de
nèfles et de la plaine saint paul qui on
a roulé à se diriger vers vers le nord
[Musique]
je voudrais dire un grand merci à toutes
les familles qui ont été patientes
mais attention je lance un appel citoyen
à tous les usagers de la route qui vont
emprunter ce pont cette nouvelle route
faisons attention à l'autre parce que je
ne veux pas qu'il y ait des accidents
mais ensemble si on fait attention et
bien nous pourrons utiliser dans les
meilleures conditions
dans un souci de sécurité pour tout le
monde